er er is thanks uh to Bram vaker and
John Smith they are both senior machine
learning scientists at booking and uh
probably uh we have all H experience
that the ETL process sometimes in our
jobs can become somehow messy especially
as the company grows or if the company
is larger fortunately they are going to
tell us about uh the concept tables as
code so the floor is yours guys thank
you for being here
so before we get started I would like a
quick raise of hands who works or has
worked with ETL workflows or yeah okay
keep your hands up so if you feel that
you test your workflows before
production enough you can keep your
hands
up
okay um and I had another question but
that that one I forgot so you can all
lower your hands um so let's get started
my name is Bram John we've already been
introduced so let's keep the small talk
here we do represent a larger group of
data scientists machine learning
scientists and Engineers uh which are
all here on screen and probably
somewhere in the room you can raise your
hands if you want no didn't show up fine
so data booking why we as booking.com
are standing here in front of you to
talk about data or D engineering well we
have dozens of PE dozens of teams
working on generally data exclusively oh
there you are why didn't you raise your
hand uh we have dozens of Team working
on data which makes for hundreds and
hundreds of data practitioners all
around the company in largely Amsterdam
but also largely outside of
Amsterdam producing thousands and
thousands of data workflows resulting in
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of data
assets and all this mostly in this talk
we'll we Face a common data headache
data design headache and we'll discuss
that now so let me
explain so it all starts with persistent
data so if I talk about persistent data
I generally talk about things stored in
S3 hdfs but it can also be part of Hive
snowflake uh Presto whatever you
run and all of this data tends to be
produced or consumed by some form of
code
obviously this code can be python which
probably most of you do but it can also
be SQL it can be DBT it can be spark can
be any language we're going to talk
mostly about spark And Hive but it would
apply to any other combination of
persistent data and
code now persistent data and code live
in very different
worlds code on the one hand persistent
data on the other hand and they don't
really touch unless they're the code is
executed in
production and what happens is that
through this producers and consumers of
data only communicate through the
persistent data in
production for example in spark if you
write a data set you simply give your
data frame give a string
location bam placed in production placed
in the persistent data world and reading
the same way but there's no guarantee
that what you expect to the read will
actually come
back as a result changes are only really
tested through this persistent data in
production leading to some form of a
YOLO deployment in many
occasions so what we need is a contract
between the consumer and producer that
lives in the land of code not in the
world of
data and this brings us to the title of
our talk tables is code
so real brief structure of the talk I'll
first introduce what are tables code so
you have a little bit of an
understanding of this and then we'll
talk about some of the
advantages customization of data access
testing makes easily easy probably the
most important part how you can use
these tests to build and deploy easily
and also how to scale these builds when
you get to thousands of
workflows and finally a very important
part of this is scaling the community
because this only works not only as
scale of data but also a scale of
community what you understand throughout
the
talk so a tabless code is simply a
contract you could see there's a
contract that lives in the target
language so it could be python for
example when we access our persistent
data we always want to flow through this
particular contract so all of the um the
rights and reads go through this
particular contract and the contract
looks something like this in our case
we've designed it as a a class so the
class here is a h table representation
of a table called
hotels we have a schema defined in the
class and um as you might be using
schema Registries this can also be
synced with the schema registry either
on read and writes or uh in another way
but importantly this exists in your code
it's not exclusively on your persistent
data side or exclusive unit data
registry and we also can add any
arbitrary other type of metadata like
format location partitions or anything
we would
like and now as developers we can
control the interface of this data asset
so here we've extended the class with a
right method that takes the class and
for example checks the schema
compatibility so before we write we
check the schema compatibility both in
production but also when we write test
integration test unit test anything
always this is
executed and we can extend it with any
arbitrary hooks we'd like so U for
example think about incode data
validation instead of relying on first
writing to a big you know um di big
staging environment we could for example
test it in tests so in unit tests we
could also check our data
consistency we could redirect source and
targets so when we don't have access to
a staging environment like we don't have
in Booking uh we can simply write in
from certain machines to personal schema
in our production environment that is
shielded
off and also we can introduce any custom
right strategy on top of whatever
language we use think about Atomic
rights or incremental rights anything
we'd like to customize we can make part
of this
object now what happens is when we want
to use this contract we simply import it
as a class and both producers and
consumers can access the interface that
we as developers create
and write through this contract to our
um persistent
data now this is the design principle
that might sound very interesting but it
really only becomes interesting for real
if we wrap this all into a monor repo
and this will be John's part of the talk
John far away all right thank you very
much Brown um I want to talk about monor
repos um specific Al this is going to
sort of close the loop on exactly you
know we talked about the principle but
how do we do it in practice the answer
is a monor repo now the word monor repo
might raise some sort of negative or
fiery emotions in some people in the
crowd uh and there might be a debate
that ensues the moment that I get off
the stage I would like to for the next
about 23 minutes close that debate uh
and then just say okay you know if you
like poly rapos that's okay we can
settle our differences uh maybe like
over drinks later
um I want to talk about this what's in
this monor repo precisely um first I'm
going to talk about local
testing um then I'm going to talk about
how we enact that local testing into
continuous
integration um and then as we scale um
there are some sort of issues that come
at scale and we're going to talk about
how basil and smart test caching were
used to solve these scaling problems
start off local testing um the point of
this whole thing you know we have a
contract between our code and our data
that is either implicit or explicit but
at the end of the day we want to
validate it we want to make sure that
the code actually matches up with what
the data uh what the data looks like and
most frequently and still and you know
still quite frequently what happens is
that you're going to do this in PR
you're going to write your code based on
your own understanding of the data um
and then you're going to put it into
either a staging environment that's
tested up against production data or
you're going to actually just put it up
into production and then after 45
minutes of runtime you're going to see a
surprise column KN down exception oh
well it was me now I have to make the
change and wait another 45 minutes to
see if it ran this is of course quite a
common
workflow um if you can instead validate
this code and data contract locally um
then you have speed on your side um you
don't you don't have the the uh the io
inefficiencies that would come with
testing in prod um you don't end up with
the surprise exceptions in PR after 45
minutes instead you end up with them
locally in about you know 45 seconds uh
which you know at the end of the day
what we really want is a faster
development cycle I make a change I see
if that change worked I want to wait as
little time as possible before I see
that happen and that's a good
development
experience um the way that we can do
this the way that we can validate these
the code and data contracts on a local
machine
is through testing unit and integration
testing um for those who in the audience
who have had this Revelation and have
tried to do local testing with spark and
with databases there's a set of common
headaches that you've probably
encountered at least once for one thing
setting up local spark is a little bit
of a pain uh having a local database
that spark is going to be writing into
just on everybody's machine well that's
also kind of painful and then you're
going to have to set up mock data with
mock schemas and then you're going to
have to mock the read and write
interfaces and then make sure that
nothing's actually accidentally touching
prod which which tends to which can tend
to happen in situations like this um and
then also wrap everything in a nice
clean setup and tear down phase so that
you your tests aren't actually touching
each other um this is a lot of boiler
plate a really significant amount of
stuff and so what we've done to make
this whole thing of very pleasant
developer development experience that
we've handled it um I want to talk about
exactly what that's going to look like
for somebody who's writing a test in
this monor repo for example you see we
have this is an example of a uh of a
test uh at least the beginning of one
and for those of you that are familiar
with pi test uh you can see that there's
an argument to that function that's a hi
database um if you're not familiar with
P test fixtures basically what this is
is that you know for every test that's
written in the monor repo for the
duration of that test every test has its
own special copy of a blank Hive
database that they're free to do with
what they want and it's cleaned up
afterwards and in this case what we're
doing is you know we're creating this
we're importing this hotel's object the
table as the hotel table as code um and
we're adding it to this database it
doesn't have any data yet but we're just
adding it with the schema that we
expected to
have um this fixure is globally
available and erased after every single
test ensuring isolation of your tests um
the most important thing here is that
when you are creating mock data in your
unit tests quite frequently you have to
repeat the schema so then when you
change the schema you have to change it
twice this is not efficient and this is
not really the best unit testing
practices um especially because it you
know it leaves leaves you open to typo
typo errors quite frequently um you have
a significantly reduced chance of typos
and less development effort uh when you
can just import the schem mode directly
from an object
um these tests naturally are going to be
for some kind of ETL pipeline
function uh so let's see what one of
those is going to look like let's say
we've got process Hotel
pipeline um what it's going to do it's
very simple we're going to uh load up
the hotel's table we're going to then
run some some function that we've
created called get available rooms uh
and then we're going to write the
available rooms data frame that resulted
from that function into our available
room
table easy we load it we transform it
and then we we write
it so let's say that hypothetically this
function accesses a numb rooms column in
the hotel DF um and then we need to
actually test this code to verify that
the num rooms column actually exists in
your production
code this is quite easy now because you
can just create an empty table with this
predefined schema that may or may not
contain the num rooms column uh and then
you have this that just runs the code
this is partially a power of the of the
framework and partially one of the
powers of spark is that you can run a
test without any data just blank data
frames with correct schemas and this
ends up being an incredibly powerful
test um for one thing it will fail
immediately if the input table has no
num rooms column which is exactly what
you wanted to verify in the first place
um and most importantly there's no data
needed uh and that also reduces the
overhead needed to create create the
test in the first
place um and let's say okay well you
just said No data needed but I actually
have functionality that's required to
create data um and then the other nice
thing is that when we have the table
defined in a as a table as code um we
can also have a write interface to that
table um where we can just create data
and write to it and we don't need to
redefine the table
again um most importantly another beauty
of spark is that you don't need to write
every column some tables have like
hundreds of columns your unit test
shouldn't have hundreds of columns
ideally they only need one of them or
two um so we've got unit testing we've
got unit testing and integration testing
down but we want to at least
continuously confirm that these tests
are being run that they're correct and
that they're actually covering as much
Behavior as we want it to and that's
where continuous integration comes into
play um so we use gitlab CI extensively
some of you likely use um any other
types of CI but more or less the
landscape of it is going to look about
the same we've got a um a testing step
that's going to run automatically all of
our unit tests all of our integration
tests and check to make sure that we
have coverage that's important I'll get
in that in a in another uh in a later
slide and then importantly for usability
once every single time that something is
merged to master it's deployed to our
internal piie as a new package so that
all the code that's written there can be
imported and installed basically from
anywhere in the
company uh this is really this is a
really nice experience it's uh it's it
reduces the the need for conversations
of well how can I install your code well
it's right there it's all in the same
place um one important thing here is
that all the tests have to pass before
we do any kind of merge to master um
this is really important in conjunction
with um code coverage the idea is that
you know in a monor repo there's a bit
of a social contract that you have you
have your code coexisting with other
people's code and you have the
opportunity if you change your code you
can break other people's code but with
this um with this in place we
effectively prevent that um you are not
even allowed to merge your code if your
code breaks somebody else's and so being
a very important step here um another
important piece of that puzzle is 100%
line
coverage um talking about coverage can
be a little bit controversial but we can
at least confidently say that having
100% test coverage combined with what
you saw earlier this um execution plan
test where you're testing spark with
empty data um effectively it it verifies
more or less that the code and data
contract at all times for every state of
the master branch of the repository uh
is always
validated um and with that you are free
to do F Friday afternoon deployments uh
as much as you want to and at this point
we don't even maybe yeah not as much as
you want to to but you know more often
than more often than uh than
never um so when we start talking about
unit testing there's another piece of
the conversation we have to we have to
look at that is that um there are a lot
of these things you know if you're
really passionate about unit tests some
people may have written thousands of
these things um and the the runtime of
these gets really long especially in a
modor repo setting um so if you see
thousands of tests some of them are big
some of them are small just running this
on one hour can take upwards of an hour
running this on one machine can take
upwards of an hour maybe even upwards of
two hours this is just unacceptable for
a continuous integration pipeline um so
what do we do well we observe that not
every test needs to be run in every
change especially if the monaru is
spanning a lot of different teams across
the business if I change my code in in
marketing I shouldn't have to run the
tests in security that doesn't doesn't
make any sense so this brings us to talk
about basil for people who are not
familiar with basil it's basically a
build system that allows you to build
incrementally and only um and only make
only test the changes that you
absolutely need to test based on
dependencies that you specified so it
also allows you to specify dependencies
between code
explicitly um and I'll show you I'll
illustrate a little bit what this looks
like in practice um before using basil
um we quite simply we just represented
the entire monor repo as just a just one
package really one colossal python
package with a bunch of um tables say
code artifacts and a bunch of code
artifacts and then we test everything
all the time this of course um uh ran
ran out of its welcome very quickly as
the tests quickly started to take way
too long to run the key Insight with
with basil is representing every schema
for your data sets and every pipeline
has its own small python
package uh the benefit that you get from
this is that you this allows you to tell
Basil hey you know pipeline X depends on
table a and pipeline y depends on table
B which then allows you to say well I
only changed table a so I only need to
test these pipelines so then you end up
with instead of your tests running in an
hour they take maybe like 30
seconds this is really powerful and
allows us to scale much much
faster um there's an important aspect of
this diagram is that it kind of looks
like what the first thing that the BR
showed which is basically that before we
had these contracts implicitly and they
were tested through production taking a
lot of time and only basically
communicating through the errors that
they brought each other now this
contract is represented
explicitly um and is able to be tested
locally relatively instantly this is a
real upgrade from the from the old
system um so all these things are these
are great technical details but this did
not come from nowhere basically the
surrounding this whole um surrounding
the entire monor repo and the tables'
code concept there's a lot of
salesmanship that has to be done in
order to convince people to use it and
um and a lot of a lot of people involved
and that leads me to talk about
Community I want to have like one point
which is that like some people might be
thinking like well if this is such so
obviously better than the other solution
and then why don't all the managers get
together and tell the practitioners that
they have to be using it starting next
week well the reality is that may maybe
similar with a lot of other companies
booking doesn't really work like that if
it's very bottom up and if we want to
have people using a different product
then we have to um convince them to use
it so the way it began was a single
product team um this is a really
effective dog fooding strategy because
when their production pipelines were on
it now suddenly well you really need you
really need it to work right um so they
didn't want to spend all their time
manually writing down schemas in Python
classes um so they created a command
line interface that allows you to pull
directly from the existing schema
registry and generate the classes based
on the schema registry especially
convenient when there's like over a 100
columns in some
tables uh and really doing that for any
common operation gives you a lot of
extra speed up um through the through
the magic of of how how good this was
for that for that one team people hear
about it people sell it aggressively um
and it grew kind of organically uh
across some other teams in the similar
area and now when other people from
other teams are using it well okay now
our knowledge is not so Universal now we
need sort of easy interfaces to things
um and that's where of course you're
running your testing you should be
providing a Docker image so that
everybody can run it on their machine uh
without having to do a bunch of setup
up um as it gets easier and easier to
use gets more features and more more
users and people talking about it
gradually it reaches critical mass it
starts growing along teams and then we
we end up in a network network effect a
network effect situation where people
are telling each other about it and
other folks are using it
um this is a lot of stuff to support
these are a lot of people using these
things so how do we support um support a
community and how do we keep growing it
there's three main things that we do
here um communication and support is
super important um for all the people
that are using the monor repo maybe
they'll have bugs here and there we
routinely communicate with them through
slack and have a support Channel where
all the maintainers help people out um
we treat it necessarily we treat it as
internal open source so like if you come
in and you want to make a change there's
something that you want to want to add
to the framework go ahead you know send
us a merge requests and then we'll
will'll make it happen um and then uh
also quite importantly we train people
we upskill people on using this uh using
this framework especially if there's a
lot of stuff to be a lot of new stuff to
learn about how to use it then we we
bring on newcomers to this framework and
we have all day training sessions here
and
there um where has this all brought us
uh at this stage well so right now we
this this supports 384 ETL pipelines
growing really rapidly it's basically
doubling every year um and so I wouldn't
be surprised by the time I finish
speaking it's
um so it supports about 25 teams across
the company right
now um it includes not just ETL but also
model training
pipelines uh and as a matter of
convenience for people with with
pipelines there's also some alerting and
monitoring libraries that they can use
to really juice up their juice up their
workflows um where are we looking to in
the future well basically growing um we
want to continue onboarding
teams uh we want to continue on boing
more data sources and then finally you
know given the the potential for
interest we could maybe look into open
sourcing it and uh that's that's
everything thank you very
much